dave i i've
said it for a long time and i've got
some awesome
liberal friends
awesome yeah
but
i have
always
faced discrimination bigotry jealousy
from white liberals
that's been the story of my career that
there have been some that have been
tremendous to me and i've written about
them called them out by name but overall
what the white liberal how they feel
comfortable helping black people is like
oh can i bend over and help you out poor
negro
and then when i help you out
make sure you put it on your resume that
i helped you out and maybe i'm gonna
tell everybody and and and you know what
for me helping you out
never say a word i disagree with
because if you do exactly you've sold me
out and you're an ungrateful person
and
i just
i don't want to generalize but you know
about conservatives but what
conservatives have generally done in
this business as it relates to me is
like oh man how can we make money
dave i've seen people
this is one of the craziest things i saw
in the in the media i saw a guy on tv
that told a story
i think during the height of the george
floyd or
one of these
eric garner one of these moments
went on tv
and said
that he and his wife
had decided that they would no longer
let their 18 year old son
drive a car because they were so
petrified of the police
and
and i was just sitting there and again
this is the kind of if i was the
commissioner of one of these sports i
would clown suit this guy because i
would just go hold on man
you're so afraid of the police that
you're not gonna let your black son
drive a car
are you going to let him go to a party
with other black boys
because statistically
his chances of being killed by somebody
are a thousand times greater
by another 18 year old black boy
than the police so maybe you should pass
you can't run around with black boys
and then i now go ahead and respond to
that that i would and they wouldn't have
they would have nothing to say america
could see these are clowns
these are people that are just saying
[ __ ] on tv to draw attention to
themselves to to make sure that the
checks come in from msnbc
china nike whoever uh but this isn't the
truth
and so if i was a commissioner of the
nfl i just stand on truth
and and i would you know but roger he's
not equipped for this argument or this
time
and
you know ownership scared but at some
point
they men are going to have to be men
again
and men
that
understand how good this country has
been to us and our families i'm gonna
have to stand up
and and and
fight this fight and quit hiding it's
one of the main reasons i left corporate
media because i you know
i wanted to get in the fight for real i
want the gloves off and let's let's pick
up these muskets and let's mow down some
of these idiots that are trying to tear
this country down
so i'm guessing you're not getting any
calls from uh good old joy ann reed over
at msnbc for these conversations
i wish she would call me dave
because what i would like to i'd like to
introduce her to a beautician who can
get her to settle on a hairstyle
because every time you turn on that damn
tv she got a new hairstyle new wig she's
culture she's culturally appropriated
from every race on the planet with her
hairstyle
one day is wilma roonall uh wilma oh
who is
you just never know from day to day
who's who she going culturally
appropriate from hairstyle to hairstyle
and then i mean and she's one of the
biggest phonies
on tv
if
her old blogs are what she really thinks
this woman was raised in the church just
like me yeah she's on tv lying
pretending that she's some kind of
leftist and and and it's all the
collected check and it
those are the those are the real
sellouts
those are the people selling out what
they really believe
for money and then they sit around and
they want to call tim scott they want to
call him
more
and all this stuff
so yeah no i won't be getting a call
from joyrie
yeah and i you know not that not that
twitter is much of a barometer of
anything other than the general hate of
the world but you know i see what people
say to you we talked about it last time
you know you'll make a political comment
or a sports or a societal comment and
then the things that they will say to
you as a black man the supposedly
tolerant people it's it's just
extraordinary and it just it just never
ends
dave i i've
said it for a long time and i've got
some awesome
liberal friends
awesome yeah
but
i have
always
faced
discrimination bigotry jealousy
from white liberals that's been the
story of my career that there have been
some that have been tremendous to me and
i've written about them called them out
by name but overall
what the white liberal how they feel
comfortable helping black people is like
oh can i bend over and help you out poor
negro
and then when i help you out
make sure you put it on your resume that
i helped you out and maybe i'm gonna
tell everybody and and you know what for
me helping you out
never say a word i disagree with
because if you do exactly you've sold me
out and you're an ungrateful person
and
i just
i don't want to generalize but you know
about conservatives but what
conservatives have generally done in
this business as it relates to me is
like oh man how can we make money
and that that's that's it
it's
what you need how can we make money with
the liberal it's
hey man you got to pledge allegiance to
everything that i believe in
and then
we can make some money but you better
thank me every day when you come in here
that i allowed you to make this money
and
i just yeah
that's what i think babe
no i i got you i got you
you'll appreciate this couple days ago
because i told you i don't i don't watch
the new games anymore i watch these old
games on youtube and i was watching the
92 finals you know that's the jordan
shrug year and they're they're
interviewing clyde the glide i've got a
ball sign from him right behind me here
and they start asking him about race
out of nowhere and you may remember
clyde never had an opinion on anything
he never really commented on anything it
wasn't his it wasn't his thing
and they keep trying to get him to
comment on race and then they go uh it's
a white interviewer by the way he's
still in the biz i'll tell you who he is
after it's not we don't need to throw
him under the bus right now uh and he
goes he goes well jordan you know with
all his success and all his influence
like shouldn't he be doing more to make
sure racism doesn't exist in america and
everything else and clyde who never said
anything really interesting outside of
basketball he goes you know he's a
basketball player he's working on his
craft he's not a politician and i was so
freaking relieved to hear it that this
guy who i love because of his skill said
something sensible and that was 1992 30
years ago you could say something
sensible and you wouldn't be now he
would be called to sell out for saying
that basically
and potentially run out of the nba he
would definitely get a suspension they
come up with some reason to suspend him
how dare you
say that racism isn't
the the number one thing and that
michael jordan who's a basketball player
must take a position on that
it what clyde said there is 1000
sensible
look
it's so hard to compete at the level
that jordan clyde drexer and these guys
did
if people think
that when jordan's at the height of his
career
that he's also studying up on
geopolitical issues and domestic issues
the guy just had some self-awareness
like i'm gonna stay in my lane
i'm a basketball player right now
why don't y'all go ask uh the
politicians or
the the historians or activists or
whatever why are you asking me as a
basketball player and it's one of those
selfish things
that we in the media did
because we all
this generation the generation of sports
journalists that didn't
get to cover muhammad ali
didn't get to cover
the impact of the vietnam war and the
civil rights movement on america
those of us that didn't we want to redo
it and we want to turn lebron james into
muhammad ali and i've said this and
many many times
lebron james is a basketball player he's
not that smart listen to him talk
uh listen go read his twitter feed his
instagram he can barely spell but y'all
think
this guy is some kind of uh
thought leader public intellectual
whatever
and then the number one thing because i
you know his lack of
grammar and all that i could almost deal
with that but what what the media
won't deal with is that
muhammad ali whether we like the nation
of islam or not he was connected and
controlled by a religious sec
and elijah muhammad malcolm x whether we
like them or not very smart people
ahead of the curve
they control muhammad ali said what they
told him to say and did what they told
him to do at that time lebron james
ain't connected to nobody but nike and
phil knight phil knight is not elijah
muhammad or malcolm x
and so who's
who who's advised adam mendelson or and
i know adam mendelson the pr guy that
works right but he ain't malcolm x or
elijah muhammad
expecting any of these these athletes
can barely keep up with their baby mamas
how the hell they gonna keep up with
what's going on in the rest of the world
uh
it's just it's
we keep putting them in this position we
keep oh who gonna be the next muhammad
ali and and and we have to accept those
days are gone
the athletes today
make millions of dollars live in gated
communities
next to people who look like dave rubin
and they're not
in the hood they're not connected to the
working class
black americans or white americans the
way they used to be
these are the elites they've been led
into the club
that's why they go through these little
rituals uh
of putting dresses on like russell
westbrook and everybody go through these
humiliation rituals uh so they can be
led into the club
they're not speaking for the working
class person anymore they're speaking
for nike they're speaking for china
they're speaking for their pocketbooks
we need to cut it out asking these guys
to do things they're incapable of doing
i almost feel sorry for them it's like
it it would almost be like uh
if somebody asked hey spend the night at
mcdonald's and never eat a double filet
of fish sandwich it's not gonna happen
today it's not gonna happen if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell